la palabra arbitraje puede sonar muy
sofisticada pero realmente trata de un
concepto muy sencillo se trata de tomar
ventaja de las diferencias en los
precios de esencialmente lo mismo una
misma cosa para tener ganancias sin
ningún riesgo vamos a pensar en esto con
más detalle digamos que en una parte de
la ciudad hay un tipo de mercado digamos
que es un mercado de manzana y digamos
que en ese mercado las manzanas se
venden vamos a inventar algún precio
aquí digamos que esas manzanas se venden
a un dólar por cada manzana un dólar por
manzana
y digamos que en otra parte de la ciudad
hay otro mercado es un mercado de frutas
y en este otro mercado las manzanas se
venden se van a vender por un dólar con
50 centavos por manzana bueno como
podemos tomar ventaja de esta diferencia
de precios y vamos a asumir que estas
manzanas son idénticas cómo podemos
tomar ventaja de la diferencia de
precios entre estas manzanas en los
diferentes mercados para tener una
ganancia libre de riesgos
bueno idealmente querríamos vender
manzanas en el mercado más caro en donde
podemos obtener un dólar con 50 por
manzanas y queremos comprar manzanas en
el mercado que es más barato en donde se
venden a un dólar y eso es exactamente
lo que vamos a hacer vamos a este
mercado compramos nuestras manzanas a un
dólar no se compramos 10 manzanas 10
manzanas por 10 dólares y luego tomamos
nuestra bicicleta y nos vamos al otro
mercado y ahí en ese mercado vamos a
vender nuestras 10 manzanas aquí es
comprar
las 10 manzanas por 10 dólares y aquí va
a ser vender 10 manzanas a 15 dólares
las 10 manzanas
por lo que tenemos una ganancia libre de
riesgos de 5 dólares compramos a 10
vendimos a 15 nos quedan 5 dólares
libres y podemos repetir esto una y otra
vez en cada viaje compramos todas las
manzanas que quepan en nuestra bicicleta
las vamos a vender y continuamos ganando
dinero y de esto se trata el arbitraje
pero tiene un efecto colateral si
alguien hace estos suficientes veces lo
que va a pasar es incrementar la
cantidad de manzanas en el segundo
mercado aquí se aumenta la cantidad de
manzanas y en este otro mercado la
demanda se va a incrementar porque se
están llevando las manzanas de aquí y lo
que eventualmente va a suceder es que la
demanda al subir va a ocasionar que se
aumenten los precios
y en el otro mercado va a pasar lo
contrario va a hay más cantidad de
manzanas y el precio va a bajar así que
en teoría si se sigue repitiendo esto
mientras más veces se repita estos
precios se van a acercar cada vez más
entre ellos y eventualmente no se podrá
tener ninguna ganancia al respecto pero
mientras haya esa diferencia se tiene
una oportunidad para hacer arbitraje